the number of international fighters
helping ukraine is growing by the day
and the ukrainian government says that
more than 16 000 total now foreign
fighters have arrived in the country in
just the last few days we have met
several americans who say they are too
planning to help ukrainian forces in
fact they are over the border as we
speak they told us they could just not
sit back
and watch
we landed in warsaw and saw them
immediately three americans headed for
ukraine ready to die they say in a fight
for survival against the russians and
what's the plan
the plan to help save the lives
of
of ukrainian people andrew pancheck is a
licensed truck driver who was born in
ukraine but he launched this particular
mission from bucks county pennsylvania
and while we read in his local paper
that he's never been in a battle and
used personal savings to pay for his
tickets he told us the hardest part was
leaving behind his three young children
i didn't say goodbye i said see you
see you later
while u.s soldiers are staying out of
ukraine everyday americans like this are
not specifically restricted from going
in says acting u.s ambassador to ukraine
christina cavine what does the american
government
say
to americans who are volunteering for
combat in ukraine we encourage all
americans not to travel to ukraine right
now and those americans who are in
ukraine to leave ukraine because it is
not safe closer to the border however we
caught up with bipartisan leaders of the
house foreign affairs committee
congressman gregory meeks and michael
mccall who had just seen the war's human
toll up close
how did each of you feel about our
fellow countrymen joining the fight
there i think that what they see and
what
people around the world seeing is
democracies at stake and as you know
president zielinski said to us
this is not just a fight
for ukrainian people this is a fight for
all of us it's just starting here
ukrainians have inspired the world and
these these freedom fighters i call them
but on thursday russia's military warned
foreign fighters they'd be treated as
mercenaries not as protected combatants
under international law as far as i see
civilians are not protected by
humanitarian law so i don't take much
freedom to anything they say we spotted
christopher kallus in full body armor
walking toward the checkpoint into
ukraine before the war this trained
pastry chef with no military experience
had been splitting his time between the
new york culinary scene and ukraine but
after evacuating his ukrainian wife and
baby to safety in portugal he decided to
go back not to fight he says
but to help others so you're ukrainian
by marriage but on paper you're an
american about to enter ukraine that's
correct join the war effort yes are you
worried i am absolutely worried yes but
i'm more worried for the people there
who are not able to leave is this
something you're prepared to die for yes
i want my child to have a ukraine to go
back to when she's grown up
so we lost contact with chris for a
couple days but we did hear from him
this morning no pictures but he said
he's in quote deep
as for andrews his group we did get a
picture from them they are over the
border
take a look at it there there's a sign
with ukraine on it and we also noticed
there on their car
they brought the american flag with them
still representing